Вітаю! Я Ольга Дудар. Історик
Історик, автор підручників,
вчитель, викладач.
Сподіваюся, що сьогоднішній
наш урок, який буде присвячений
життю, розвитку політичній
ситуації в українських землях
у складі Польщі в період
між двома Світовими війнами,
буде для вас цікавим і насиченим.
І звичайно, він буде дуже важливим
для тих, хто збирається складати
зовнішнє незалежне оцінювання.
Грає музична заставка.
Перш ніж ми розпочнемо
роботу з новим матеріалом,
давайте пригадаємо попередню тему
і ви дасте відповіді на дуже
прості коротенькі завдання.
Отже, подумайте, будь
ласка, і оберіть варіант:
коли було запроваджено
політику «пацифікації»?
Увага на екран
Я сподіваюся, що ви всі
пам’ятаєте, що це 1930 рік.
Пригадайте, будь ласка,
що таке «пацифікація».
Це доволі жорстокі
брутальні дії польської влади,
це тиск, який здійснювала армія,
поліція на Українські осередки.
Це розгром кооперативного руху, це
ліквідації, погроми в осередках просвіти,
наступ на активне українське селянство
з метою того, аби полонізація
українських земель,
полонізація Східної Галичини
відбувалася більш ефективно.
Зверніть, будь ласка, увагу на текст
і поміркуйте – яким словом варто
заповнити пропуск у цьому тексті.
Увага на екран
Це цитата з історичного джерела
де йдеться про польських колоністів.
Отже, як називали людей,
поляків, польських військових
і цивільне населення, які отримували
земельні наділи у Східній Галичині?
Я сподіваюсь, що ви запам’ятали
осадництво. Політика «осадження».
Для більш ефективної колонізації уряд
напрявлав поляків етнічних, військових,
цивільне населення у сільську місцевість
і надавав їм на пільгових
умовах земельні ділянки.
І також, хочу повернутися
до того домашнього завдання,
яке ви отримали на попередньому уроці.
Я просила вас поміркувати
– які наслідки отакої політики
польського уряду у
західноукраїнських землях,
тих землях, які були
підконтрольні саме Польщі.
Увага на екран. Отже, перше – це
асиміляція. Поляки всіма силами:
і державними заходами, і впливом на
освіту, і політикою «осадництва» намагалися …
І навіть взагалі йшлось про те, щоб
взагалі не вживати слово «український»
і щоб створити ілюзію,
що це польські території, які
випадковим чином опинилися на деякий
час поза межами польської держави.
Щодо економіки.
Політику польського уряду, я
вважаю, можна назвати колоніальною,
ви можете не погоджуватися, якщо
ви прочитали додаткові матеріали, але
українські землі були і сферою,
де поляки збували готову продукцію
і джерелом різних ресурсів, і сировини.
І звичайно, звідси можна
було отримати трудові ресурси,
адже кількість українців, які заробляли
мало і які проживали в сільській місцевості
– їм було важко буквально
заробити собі на прожиття
і польська економічна
політика всіляко цьому сприяла.
Крім того, жорстоке придушення національного
супротиву, насправді мало зворотній ефект.
Були і селянські повстання,
активізується діяльність
українських партій різного спрямування.
І ми сьогодні з вами про це поговоримо.
Але найнегативніший результат – це те, що
ситуація в Україні розхитувала
ситуацію в Польщі загалом.
І лише напружувала
міжнаціональне протистояння
між поляками і українцям,
які насправді, в умовах кризи,
в умовах складних викликів
міжвоєнного періоду,
в умовах можливого компромісу,
діяли б набагато ефективніше.
Отже, ми з вами маємо поговорити
сьогодні про політичні партії.
Як би там не було, Польська
республіка – це не тоталітарний режим
і в рамках закону можна було
створювати політичні партії,
можна було брати участь
у виборах, і звичайно,
що серед польських депутатів
та парламентарів були й українці.
Проте всі політичні партії, які діяли
від українських земель у складі Польщі,
ми з вами можемо умовно
поділити на три основні групи.
Перша група – це пропольські.
Вони не повністю підтримували
ідеї і курс польської влади,
але вони діяли в межах закону,
сподіваючись таким чином
добитись поставленої мети.
Далі – це прорадянські. Вони,
напевно, мали найменший вплив.
І доволі, скажімо так … сильні,
впливові - це самостійницькі партії.
Найпопулярнішою серед всіх
українських партій, які діяли легально,
стало Українське національне
демократичне об’єднання.
Його частіше називають по
абревіатурі УНДО. Чому так трапилось?
Перший фактор, що УНДО виникло у 1925 році
на базі інших поміркованих
політичних партій.
Хто підтримував УНДО?
Це заможні селяни, це інтелігенція,
це партійні діячи з досвідом
ще за часів Австро-Угорської імперії,
ЗУНР, які були визнаними лідерами думок,
які дійсно мали вплив і авторитет.
Ще важливу роль в популяризації УНДО
відіграла українська
Греко-Католицька церква,
оскільки священники доволі
часто вступали до цієї партії.
То звичайно підтримувало духівництво,
але іще, що дуже важливо, це засоби дій.
Це ось ті легальні способи боротьби
для Греко-Католицької
церкви були дуже важливі.
Яку мету ставили собі представники УНДО?
Це досягти соборності, досягти
посилення України, ймовірно незалежності,
але лише легальними методами.
Відповідно вони намагалися
брати активну участь у виборах
і пробували різну тактику боротьби.
Коли на чолі партії став Василь Мудрий,
він і його оточення
започаткували такий курс
на нормалізацію відносин
з польським урядом.
Лідери УНДО обіцяли, що вони не
будуть проводити антипольську агітацію.
Хоча насправді це було доволі складно.
Натомість, польський уряд
припиняв атаки на українців.
До певної міри ця
нормалізація була ефективною,
але після смерті Юзефа Пілсудського,
його наступники не підтримали цей курс.
Підсилюється тиск на українські землі.
І це ще мало таке логічне пояснення:
польський уряд розумів, що він на
кордоні з нацистською Німеччиною.
І розумів, що, скоріш за все, вектор
нападу це і польські землі в тому числі.
І для того, щоб бути
сильними, поляки вирішують,
що треба всі ці внутрішні кризові моменти
ліквідувати і, на жаль, для цього
запроваджувати тиск, а не компроміс.
Тому після зміни отакого політичного
курсу, популярність УНДО знижується.
Щодо прорадянських партій, то,
звичайно – це Комуністична партія.
Тут все не було так просто,
комуністи теж мали різні думки.
Спочатку існувала Комуністична
партія Східної Галичини.
Але, коли вже остаточно,
в міжвоєнний період,
доля Східної Галичини
склалася так, що Антанта визнала
приналежність їх земель
до Польської республіки,
прийняли рішення, що ця
комуністична партія Східної Галичини,
має об’єднатися с Польською
Комуністичною партією.
Не всі українці погоджувалися з цим.
Як ви думаєте, чому?
Тут відігравало роль національне питання.
Через те, що українські
комуністи, я думаю, розуміли,
що все-таки поляки будуть
захищати інтереси своїх.
Але взагалі для комуністичної доктрини
оце національне питання
вважалось другорядним.
Врешті-решт, комуністична партія
на теренах західноукраїнських земель
не була такою популярною,
хоча вони намагались
брати учать у легальній
політичній діяльності
через створення цього
українського селянського робітничого
об’єднання, так званий «сільроб».
Вони підтримували селянські повстання,
партія була успішною тоді, коли
загострювалась економічна криза,
але врешті-решт, насправді
такого масового впливу,
комуністи в Польщі не мали.
Через посилення тиску.
Через оті заходи, про які ми з вами
згадували на попередньому уроці.
Я сподіваюсь, ви пам’ятаєте –
«пацифікація»,
і, насамперед, «полонізація».
Велику прихильність,
особливо серед молоді,
отримують націоналістичні об’єднання.
Плюс, давайте пригадаємо.
На теренах Західної України
були ті, хто мав військовий досвід
у лавах українських січових стрільців.
Люди, які розумілись на політиці
та люди, які хотіли швидких рішень,
які не хотіли терпіти
таку польську політику.
Один із таких діячів -
це Євген Коновалець.
На нього потрібно звернути увагу.
По-перше, ті хто будуть складати ЗНО з
історії, ви маєте розрізняти його портрет.
І взагалі дуже важливо
запам’ятати хто це.
Євген Коновалець - військовий.
Він був учасником першої світової війни,
якраз в лавах українських
січових стрільців.
Він був доволі важливою
людиною в лавах армії ЗУНР,
він приймав участь в діях цієї армії
на території Наддніпрянської України,
врешті-решт діяв в еміграції у 1920
році з метою саме озброєної боротьби.
Напевно Євген Коновалець
розумів, що легальними способами
досягти української незалежності,
особливо тієї частинки України,
яка знаходилась під владою тоталітарного
радянського режиму, буде неможливо.
Коли ми говоримо про
важливого історичного діяча,
особливо якщо це політичний
лідер, бажано розуміти яким він був.
Зверніть будь ласка увагу на
дошку і ще раз давайте повторимо
чим займався Євген Коновалець.
Він військовий. Він в часи
І Світової війни побував у полоні.
Він полковник армії УНР, він командир УВО,
голова проводу українських
націоналістів і перший голова ОУН.
Зрозуміло, що його ідея націоналістична
і він хотів незалежності
української держави.
Це була не просто яскрава
особистість і політичний лідер.
Від його діяльності залежало дуже багато.
Зокрема він велику увагу
присвячував будові ідеологічній ідеї ОУН.
Крім того, живучі в
еміграції, Євген Коновалець
добивався, аби українське
питання підіймала Ліга Націй.
Його така активність непокоїла як
поляків, так і радянську владу в Москві.
Крім того, він хотів розвивати
мережу націоналістичного підпілля
на теренах Української Радянської
Соціалістичної Республіці.
І врешті-решт радянська
влада вирішила його ліквідувати.
Це була таємна, доволі
масштабна спецоперація.
Перші замахи на Євгена
Коновальця були невдалими.
Врешті-решт радянський
агент переконав Коновальця,
що він представляє неіснуючу
націоналістичну організацію
на теренах більшовицької
радянської України.
Він розповідав про те, що
насправді є люди, які підтримують
ідею незалежності української держави,
і у 1938 році замах на Євгена
Коновальця був успішний та він загинув.
Ось цей радянський агент на зустріч
в кафе приніс коробку, нібито цукерок,
на коробці був гарний
орнамент. Коли він пішов
і коробка змінила положення – стався
вибух і Євген Коновалець загинув.
Якби він не був небезпечним,
активним, успішним,
навряд чи більшовицька влада докладала
би таких зусиль для його ліквідації.
Тому, ще раз хочу наголосити,
кожен історичний діяч,
чи характеризуємо ми його
позитивно, чи характеризуємо
ми його негативно – він іще й особистість.
Тому, щоб розуміти його
вплив, його роль, бажано знати
і такі якісь цікаві характеристики
його біографії і його розвитку
саме як людини.
І він ініціює створення
української військової організації УВО.
УВО діяло методами терору,
іноді закликами боротьби і це не
була єдина націоналістична організація.
Коли стало зрозуміло,
що розрізненні отакі групи,
вони не досягають бажаного
ефекту, зрештою у 1929 році
націоналістичні організації об’єднуються
в єдину Організацію
українських націоналістів.
Питання ОУН для нас дуже
важливе і ви маєте запам’ятати
цю дату – 1929 рік.
Лідером став Євген Коновалець,
авторитет якого був дуже високий.
А ідеологом Дмитро Донцов.
І давайте згадаємо про його
інтегральний націоналізм детальніше.
Отже, Дмитро Донцов свої
ідеє проголошував ще за часів
Першої світової війни.
Чого він хотів? Соборної України.
І інтегральний націоналізм визначав
існування незалежної
української держави як вищу мету.
І для цього треба було
використовувати різні засоби,
зважаючи на реальну ситуацію
в тогочасних українських землях.
Ця ідеологія була дуже популярною,
оскільки треба зважати на
ситуацію після І Світової
війни, коли українці обох частин
тоді розділеної України і
територія Наддніпрянської України,
і західноукраїнські землі
не змогли добитися успіху
у створені незалежних держав.
І одне із питань, яке
піднімали націоналісти,
це нерозуміння цінності власної держави.
Що люди більше цікавились
економічними питаннями,
питаннями соціальними,
а от питання державності,
а от тоді вже забезпечення
всіх інших потреб,
націоналісти вважали першочерговим.
ОУН використовувала різні методи і ці
методи дуже часто були жорсткими силовими.
Це і саботаж, і напади на
маєтки польських поміщиків,
демонстрації, страйки, заклики
до бойкоту польських товарів.
Асортимент таких дій,
насправді, був дуже широкий.
Найгучнішою справою, яка
виводить на політичну арену
одного із лідерів українського
націоналізму Степана Бандеру
– це вбивство міністра внутрішніх
справ Польщі Б. Перацького.
Чому замах був скоєний на нього?
Його вважали одним із ініціаторів
і ідеологів оцієї пацифікації.
Його жорстке ставлення до українського
питання викликало осуд серед українців
і ОУН вирішило продемонструвати…
Насправді, було і до цього УВО
намагалося робити замах на Пілсудського,
показати, що отакий тиск на українські
землі не залишиться безкарним.
Польська влада заарештувала
ініціаторів, тих хто влаштував цю акцію
і суд, який відбувся над Степаном
Бандерою і його спільником,
присудив їх до смертної кари, яка
потім була замінене на довічне ув’язнення.
Питання українського націоналізму,
насправді, зараз в
українському суспільстві,
коли пройшло стільки років, майже
сто, викликає великий шквал емоцій.
Я закликаю вас бути
логічними і бути поміркованими.
Насправді, націоналізм в міжвоєнний
період був популярною доктриною,
політичною ідеологією не
тільки в українських землях.
Але особливість націоналізму в
українських землях полягала в тому,
що українці боролися за
створення власної державності.
Якщо ми з вами пригадаємо
принципи повоєнної організації світу,
то Вудро Вільсон закликав визнавати
права малих націй на власну державність.
Українці боролись за
власну державу досить давно.
І коли люди бачили, по-перше:
жорсткі дії польського уряду,
по-друге: обмежену успішність
легальної політичної боротьби.
Особливо молодь була розчарована.
Дуже часто молодим людям хочеться
швидкого ефекту, швидкого
рішення своїх важливих питань.
І плюс націоналісти –
люди з великим досвідом,
люди які вміли гарно переконувати,
люди, які реагували швидко
на оці болісні питання,
які виникали у західноукраїнських землях.
Тому їх популярність абсолютно логічна.
Не всі українці підтримували ОУН.
Наприклад, митрополит Шептицький,
про якого ми згадували з
вами на минулому занятті,
говорили про те, що він визнаний лідер,
активний політичний діяч,
активний громадський діяч, меценат.
Він такі дії засуджував.
Він мав власний досвід
політичної діяльності,
боротьби за виборчі права, пригадайте,
будь ласка, на території Австро-Угорщини.
Він наголошував на тому, що
краще поступово легальна боротьба.
Проте все-таки українські
націоналісти були
креативними людьми і,
напевно, ось ця віра в ідею...
Дуже часто люди захоплюються ідеями тих,
хто в неї вірить і хто вміє
запалювати інших своєю вірою.
Тому я закликаю вас,
коли ви прослухали мене,
обов’язково прочитайте
матеріал в підручнику
і порівняйте мої висновки, моє
бачення цього політичного розвитку
з тим, що представляють наші науковці,
наші педагоги в різних підручниках.
Крім того, я закликаю вас
зробити домашнє завдання.
Для того, щоб ви це
систематизували і розуміли особливості
діяльності різних політичних сил, ви
можете записати його у формі таблички.
Чому таблички?
Через те, що коли ви
обмежені в певному просторі,
ви не будете виписувати
чогось дуже багато.
Коли ви виписуєте основне і шукаєте
в тексті або в відео основні моменти,
то ваш мозок фіксує і запам’ятовує
саме те, з чим ви працюєте.
Тому я прошу вас визначити, які
політичні сили були найпопулярніші
в землях підконтрольних Польщі,
визначити їхню мету,
чого вони хотіли досягти.
І тут ви побачите, що
і демократичні партії,
які діяли легально, і
українські націоналісти,
які вдавалися до
нелегальних способів боротьби,
насправді, мали одну мету,
але діяли різними способами.
І, наприклад, націоналісти і
комуністична партія, які мали різну мету,
часто використовували
схожі методи боротьби.
І ось коли ви це
узагальните, ви зрозумієте,
ви створите для себе чітку картинку
– як же ж все таки розвивалось
політичне життя на українських теренах
у складі Польщі в міжвоєнний період.
Я чую дзвоник.
Сподіваюсь, що я не
була надто багатослівна,
зорієнтувала вас на найважливіші аспекти
і це допоможе вам краще орієнтуватися
в шаленому просторі
надзвичайно цікавої історії України.
Дякую Вам!